[Musique]
le
peuple américain a été témoin de ce qui est
le plus grand
échec de toute
administration présidentielle dans l'histoire de notre
pays,
arrêtez de faire de la politique avec la vie des gens
[Musique] le
président Donald Trump a mis la
santé de l'Amérique au premier plan quel que soit le
vice-président  prétendre que l'
administration a
clairement fait cela n'a pas fonctionné quand je regarde
leur plan qui parle de
faire progresser les tests en créant de nouveaux EPI en
développant un vaccin,
cela ressemble un peu à du plagiat,
ce que Joe Biden sait un
peu
si l'administration Trump approuve  un
vaccin avant ou après les élections les
américains devraient-ils le prendre et le prendriez-
vous si donald trump nous dit
que je devrais le prendre je ne le prends pas
sénateur votre parti a passé les
trois dernières années et demie à essayer de
renverser le  résultats de la dernière
élection
lorsque joe biden était vice-président des
états-unis
le fbi a en fait espionné le président
trump et ma campagne
nous  'ai tous vu l'avalanche avec
ce que vous avez fait subir au pays
pendant près de trois ans
jusqu'à ce qu'il soit constaté qu'il n'y avait pas d'
obstruction pas de collusion affaire close
permettez-moi de dire que je pense que nous allons
gagner cette élection
[La musique]